vont trouver la chance d'hazard afin oui
un rêve avoir une ferme une belle ferme
avec tous les potentiels avec tout
l'équipement avec toi donc on ferme
modèle mais cultiver ici près de saint
jérôme dans les basses laurentides est
devenu un rêve impossible la terre coûte
vraiment trop cher quelques millions de
dollars parce que on parle pas juste de
prix de terreur qui s'approprie on parle
de 4 millions de dollars dans la région
des laurentides et de lanaudière la
valeur des terres agricoles vient de
bondir de près de 10% en un an il est en
train de rattraper la valeur des terres
de la montérégie de loin les plus chers
au québec
122 ha ici si on parle de 2 2 3 4
millions de dollars
c'est une dette que je veux laisser
fourmi pour deux trois générations pour
pièces l'hectare à peu pris 22 mille
dollars pour trouver une terre un prix
raisonnable
monsieur arfaoui a décidé de faire ce
que plusieurs québécois ont fait il ya
cent ans partir défricher la terre 600
km au nord en abitibi
maintenant je suis un chercheur
inter abitibi exactement à l'axé kobe a
c'est vrai c'est pas une ferme prête
il demande beaucoup de travail le
demande parce qu'il est à peu près la
moitié ses terres boisées
en plus il faut beaucoup de travail
grand montréal la terre agricole devient
chaque année plus difficile à
rentabiliser
on les jeunes qui veulent des mariannes
agriculture ça devient quasi en raison
du prix des terres en montérégie
anne roussel a longtemps hésité avant de
reprendre la ferme familiale
j'ai vu mes parents d'être toute leur
vie je passais mon pote agricultrice
tellement cesse avait été traumatisé
pour assurer la relève
la famille a trouvé une solution
originale vendre la terre un officier
d'utilité sociale agricole
la fiducie protège la terre et de son
côté anne roussel demeure propriétaire
des bâtiments de ferme et de la récolte
nous on al'avantage de fois cultiver
sans être locataire ni propriétaire
c'est une nouvelle catégorie qui existe
plein forme là et c'était la seule façon
pour elle de conserver la ferme
familiale ici vincent maisonneuve radio
canada montréal